closers let's talk tough talk our
president does it I do it under my
breath to the bartender who never
remembers my usual cocktail to the
abstinence on the beach it's the only
drink that's 100% effective but this
weekend
NPR dropped audio a former Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen talking tough to a
reporter on behalf of the big man
Michael Cohen's bare-knuckle tactics in
defense of Donald Trump captured on
recordings that have just been made
public what I'm going to do will be
disgusting that's beautiful that was the
first line of my wedding vows now
everyone on the left is clutching their
cruelty-free pearl saying this isn't how
people in power should talk wake up this
is exactly how real currently unindicted
lawyers practice law don't believe me
listen to self-described business rebel
Donny Deutsch I have gotten many phone
calls from lawyers over the years nasty
vicious aggressive calls from lawyers
using that kind of language and I will
sue you and you will rue the day you met
me and I will drag you in court I
promise you there are dozens and dozens
and dozens of lawyers in New York who
are hearing that conversation and
hearing their own voices yeah yeah in
fact I hear my own lawyers voice in what
Cohan said and I'll prove it by giving
my lawyer
Rick ballbuster a call
good luck downloading the memory on this
landline Moeller hey hello hey Rick
Jordan Klepper here just wanted to check
in and see if you can make my barbecue
this weekend if you call me one more
time about this limp-dick Jamboree you
call a barbecue I'm gonna grease my
whole arm and shove it up your ass to
puppet your mouth shut I'll be there
Yeah right glad to hear it I'm not done
you chatty scrotum I'm making a sangria
a nice summery white sangria and I don't
want any judgments about the fruit being
too soggy its marinated you feckless
which is something that I say all the
time so why would I or anyone like me
ever complain about how cool well I
can't wait to see you there listen I
gotta go I got another job I'm advising
a very stable genius on how to pull out
of NAFTA which might as well stand for
North American terrible agreement
now you have a good day Jordan or else
I'm gonna come up behind your dog and
I'm gonna twist his balls a full
rotation counterclockwise while your
kids stand there and watch with tears
streaming down their face looking
forward to it and Jordan you're my best
friend okay thanks me I'll see you soon
good of them oh love that guy
the fight continues you you a deep state
operative is sent by George Soros to
take away my Second Amendment rights and
force-feed me soy burgers no well then
prove it click and subscribe and join
the opposition now